[Música]
hablamos de revista de prensa en directo
américa ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez más ee uu rosa bienvenida
feliz martes muy buen día vamos a
comenzar hablando entonces de este
último debate electoral en chile antes
de esta primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales este domingo 21 de
noviembre fue organizado el debate ayer
por anatel la asociación nacional de
televisión pero empezamos ahora con el
país elecciones presidenciales en chile
las claves de la elección más incierta
en décadas y cierto que incierta cierto
que incierta a raúl buenos días exacto
hemos seleccionado tres medios empezamos
con el país que plantea un poco cuáles
son las claves de esta elección que pues
valga la redundancia plano se plantea
como clave para determinar el futuro del
país recuerda que más de un 20 por
ciento de chilenos todavía no se ha
decidido por qué candidato a la
presidencia al votar hay siete
candidatos de momento de momento que se
disputan la llegada a la casa de la
moneda sin embargo el debate se centra
sobre todo en dos que están en polos
opuestos del espectro político chileno
recordemos por un lado tenemos a gabriel
boric éste político salido del
movimiento estudiantil que encarna la
institucionalización del estallido
social de 2019 y que plantea seguir la
línea política de las reformas que se
exigían en la calle entonces sí que
desencadenaron en esta convención
constitucional ex extremadamente en el
otro punto del abanico político tenemos
a josé antonio kast este ultra
conservador ultra conservador
ultraderechista que ha llegado a
defender en ciertos puntos de la
herencia de pinochet y que es
completamente reaccionario
respecto a los movimientos sociales de
2019 y que se oponía de hecho ya a la
reforma constitucional vamos con la
tercera presidenciables protagonizan
intenso último debate marcado por
críticas a casas como estabas contando
los exacto lo que señala la tercera este
medio chileno es que de hecho josé
antonio kast este ultraderechista en
según los últimos sondeos es el
candidato que más opciones tiene de ser
el más votado y por eso mismo incluso el
candidato del oficialismo sebastián si
ser
luego fui al candidato al que más atacó
durante este último debate pero de hecho
todos los candidatos señalaron lo que
comentábamos no que hubiera puesto a
pinochet como ejemplo de comportamiento
democrático en sus últimos años al
frente de chile pero en segundo lugar el
segundo candidato que más recibió en
este último debate fue el izquierdista
boric que fue atacado lo típico por
simpatías con cuba con venezuela e
incluso con nicaragua como suele suceder
pues a los candidatos de izquierdas aquí
en américa latina y en otros lugares del
país antes del mundo me refiero ante lo
que él respondió que la democracia se
defiende en chile y en cualquier lugar
vamos ahora con el desconcierto y no el
desconcierto este eje o bate rosa dice
último debate contradicciones desde casa
su programa marca en la recta final de
estas elecciones exacto y es que
distintos medios han señalado esto no
como cast evidenció gran parte de sus
contradicciones en este último debate y
de hecho señalan como boris y apuntando
punto por punto a distintos elementos
que figuran en el programa del
ultraderechista del ultraderechista le
echó en cara que de implantar políticas
discriminatorias como subsidiar la salud
sólo para parejas casadas subir las
pensiones es sólo para ex miembros del
ejército entre otras cosas o no saber ni
lo que figura en su programa electoral
en términos de energía ya que dijo en su
programa electoral que va a financiar va
a aprobar sólo las termoeléctricas que
utilicen carbón de calidad algo que
luego él negó en el debate vamos a
cambiar ahora dt manejaba un lado chile
para irnos a francia vamos con limón
méxico denuncia un saqueo su patrimonio
después de una venta en parís el
artículo de frederic saliva y jari
pellet excepto este este texto hace
referencia a algo que sucedió el
miércoles pasado y es una subasta en la
conocida casa christie's en la que se
vendieron 139 obras de arte taíno y
precolombino algo que las embajadas en
francia tanto de méxico como de honduras
guatemala colombia o perú intentaron
evitar denunciando que se trata de un
saque de su patrimonio y el propio
ministro de la cultura de méxico
declaraba este medio lo mont el
patrimonio cultural no es un objeto
comercial exigimos la restitución de las
piezas su lugar es un museo porque
representan nuestras antiguas
civilizaciones algunas de las cuales
todavía siguen muy vivas a día de hoy
pero cabe recordar raúl esto no es la
primera vez que sucede y entre otras
cosas el problema recae en la
legislación francesa que deja la
restitución de estas piezas en la buena
voluntad de los coleccionistas que las
adquieren vamos ahora con liberación
quick commerce el comercio rápido es
urgente que llegue el domicilio o
cuestionarnos exacto porque este
editorial de liberación lo que comenta
es que esta nueva tendencia del comercio
express que promete que te llega a un
domicilio en menos de 10 minutos debería
hacernos el plantear con urgencia
ciertas cosas no por un lugar dice
cuándo se detendrá esta carrera de
velocidad a la satisfacción de nuestras
necesidades o deseos que alimenta el
sobre consumismo en segundo lugar está
prohibido preferir de vez en cuando la
lentitud la gestión de la frustración la
alegría de la improvisación y por último
esta garantía de respuesta a todo en
menos de 10 minutos tiene algo de
infantilizante y eso no es un poco menos
atractivo bueno rosa yo la verdad no los
sellos si quiero que prefiero un poquito
lo más rápido pero vamos ahora a hablar
de el gesto de socorro que hace la
violencia machista en un hospital y
además detienen al acompañante eso
también ocurrió en estados unidos aunque
exacto esta es una noticia de la
corporación catalana de medios
audiovisuales de los medios de
comunicación públicos de cataluña que
hace referencia a un caso que se aduce
dio a conoció a conocer ayer después o
unos días después de que se ven
popularizar a un hecho en eeuu
y es que una adolescente fue rescatada
después de hacer este gesto que indica
ser víctima de violencia machista dentro
de la furgoneta donde estaba secuestrada
algo que vio un motorista que pasó por
al lado y pudo alertar a las autoridades
y de esta forma fue esta adolescente
rescatada pues algo parecido sucedió en
barcelona en la sala espera de una
clínica del hospital en que una mujer
hizo este gesto una trabajadora de la
clínica lo supo identificar y alertó a
las autoridades sólo para recordarlo
raúl porque quien sabe a quién puede
ayudar el gesto es este recordemos y se
popularizó a través de la red tick tock
bueno rosa muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información nos vemos mañana
con más revista de prensa vamos con
nuestro primer invitado del día
[Música]